the number of lives lost to Hurricane
Dorian is rising here's why
these shanty towns never stood a chance
against the most powerful hurricane the
Bahamas has ever experienced in amongst
the flattened homes large shipping
containers scattered like building
blocks the Bahamian prime minister said
his islands were at war with hurricane
Dorian and looking down here that was no
exaggeration they have been ravished
these worst affected areas almost
obliterated you can see cars trucks
tankers strewn around like toy boats
that have made it in land and homes that
have been completely destroyed roofs
doors and windows blasted off small
sailboats were no match for this monster
even large vessels were rendered flimsy
in the face of gusts exceeding 200 miles
per hour so we're on the ground here in
one of the worst affected areas this was
the harbor completely obliterated palm
trees obviously completely flattened the
boats themselves lifted clean out of the
water onto the land by this hurricane
that came here and stayed after three
days of hell
residents like Bob cornea have finally
been brought to safety he and his wife
battled for three hours up to their
necks in seawater huge huge jetliner
crash the waves you just see the waves
crashing into our home yeah we were
totally batten totally bad everything
secure it knocked the doors and the
windows everything
your family say during the hurricane as
the lucky ones head to comfort and
shelter there are plenty of others still
living in misery the water has receded
so people are able to salvage what they
can but that's also revealed the mammoth
task ahead Amanda Walker Marsh Harbor in
the Bahamas